magnitude 7 earthquake has struck in the
aegean sea between the turkish coast
and the greek island of samos several
buildings have collapsed in turkey's
izmir province
with people trapped beneath the rubble
and reports suggest at the moment at
least four people have been
killed the earthquake struck 11 miles
off the coast
at a depth of 10 miles the tremors felt
along turkey's aegean coast and it
caused some mini tsunamis as well
in many of the low-lying coastal areas
there
it was centered northeast off the greek
island of
samos turkish media have showed the
wreckage
of a multi-story building this is in
central izmir people
climbing in to try and reach anyone who
might be trapped inside and have been
several other building collapses
through pictures that we've seen coming
in through this afternoon our europe
correspondent
adam parsons joins us now who's been
following what's happening dramatic
images coming in
um all the time adam at the moment four
four people we believe dead 120 injured
but from what we've seen of those
pictures is that likely to rise do you
think
well we're seeing i mean clearly very
significant devastation
across a wide area now when this
earthquake first happened it seemed to
be affecting both greece
and turkey so so those two countries
have both been
affected i think initial reports were
largely about greece and was striking
quite an optimistic tone
the island of samos had been hit hard
but i think then attention moved quite
rapidly to turkey
and to izmir now i think it is worth
emphasizing this was a very significant
earthquake magnitude has been
estimated at something between 6.6 and
up to 7.1
and the tremors going all the way to
istanbul in turkey to athens
in greece and some of the images we have
seen of the effects of that have been
very very striking
also uh reports of these mini tsunamis
occurring of large waves coming into
coastal areas
uh flooding but i think the main issue
at the moment
is buildings particularly older
buildings
that have collapsed that certainly has
happened in greece but clearly has
happened very significantly
in izmir and at times like this it
becomes very hard
to estimate uh casualties because of the
simple fact that
when you see huge piles of rubble it's
very very hard
immediately to know how many people were
in those buildings
which buildings have been brought down
and who frankly is underneath those
rubble so we're seeing
uh plenty of images uh of that rubble
being carved through of rescuers trying
to get to people
of course uh in the rubble uh one
hesitates to say ever that
uh that numbers of casualties will rise
but certainly at times like this it's
very very hard to come up with any exact
figures
uh adam just looking at some of the
reaction uh i think
uh in the last few moments that the
french government have offered
uh publicly any assistance that turkey
and greece might need following this
and what's happening and of course it's
all taking place during a global
pandemic isn't it and
something like this happens and we saw
it with with what happened in beirut the
horrible
explosion there and concerns about
public health around the pandemic
you know are relegated to a to a
secondary concern
when something like this happens
yeah i i think that is right and i i
mean clearly
uh at the moment covid and the effects
of it have been
devastating across so many nations
including
turkey and widespread uh across europe
very interesting actually that
that greece has had to deal with the
question of how to manage
uh covert in a place like moria the
refugee camp where people are packed in
uh so tightly that
that camp itself has had outbreaks uh
and has also had a big fire and i think
the
the greeks learnt a lot about how to
manage
infection control at a time like that
but when you have an earthquake
when you have a breakdown in in
infrastructure now
as uh i emphasize we still don't know
how much uh
damage has been done to crucial
infrastructure to water to heating to
hospitals
to ambulances and and so on that will be
important but izmir
that province and the city are at places
densely populated you are talking about
millions of people
and at a time when you have this
infection that is spreading around when
we talk about social distancing about
the importance of wearing masks
then to talk about those things at a
time when people are scrabbling through
rubble
looking for victims of this earthquake
those two things simply
may not go together so you are going to
have those twin perils of
clearly dealing with the after effects
of the earthquake but also doing
so trying somehow
to play cognizance to the effects of
coronavirus at the same time
it's not something frankly that has
happened in
in europe and turkey over the course of
the past year so we are entering in a
sense into unchelsea territory